bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro live pour cette
émission spéciale que nous avons choisi
de consacrer aujourd'hui au don
d'organes et à la greffe
ce mardi 22 juin 2021 le grand public
est invité par l' agence de la
biomédecine à la réflexion sur le don
d'organes et la greffe
alors on a estimé que c'était l'occasion
de répondre à toutes vos questions et
vos témoignages sur ce sujet pour
m'accompagner et vous éclairer et nous
éclairer puisque moi-même ça
m'intéressera évidemment j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés le professeur
maurice mimoun qui dirige le service des
grands brûlés à l'hôpital saint louis à
paris et il est également le parrain de
l'association transforme transforme
point org dont vous pouvez voir le site
internet s'afficher à l'image une
association qui sensibilise tout un
chacun le grand public au don d'organes
justement bonjour professeur mimoun
bonjour je suis ravi de vous avoir on
est très heureux de vous avoir en
plateau ce matin et en direct avec nous
vous êtes une personnalité désormais
incontournable de la chirurgie
réparatrice et du traitement des grands
brûlés et dans l'exercice de votre
métier au quotidien mais vous êtes amené
à sauver des vies en pratiquant des
greffes de peau en particulier je vous
remercie de nouvelle fois de répondre
aux questions des internautes qui
j'espère seront nombreuses et
intéressantes au fur et à mesure de
cette émission qui est consacré donc
comme je le disais au don d'organes et
au greffe et c'est un sujet qui on le
sait et on se doute qui peut vous
sembler difficile hein mais qui nous
concerne tous à vous qui nous suivait en
ce moment et bien vous n'hésitez pas à
poser toutes vos questions et à poster
vos commentaires on est en direct sur
figaro live sur lefigaro.fr et également
sur la chaîne youtube de figaro live et
comme je vous le disais le professeur
mimoun est là avec nous pour une petite
heure pour répondre à toutes vos
questions
on salue d'ores et déjà claudie terriens
qui est une internaute présente sur le
chat youtube du figaro on salue
également karen qui nous regardent
depuis la normandie
le professeur minines je disais en
introduction c'est une thématique qui
peut mettre mal à l'aise qui peut faire
peur également du coup c'est assez rare
que ce que ce sujet soit soit abordé en
fin
me ou entre amis comment on peut
désamorcer les craintes sur ce sujet et
en parler autour de soi
naturellement et sereinement il faut en
parler c'est un sujet qu'on évite mais
ce qu'il faut dire surtout c'est qu'il
faut pas culpabiliser les gens c'est
normal que ça met mal à l'aise
est ce cette gêne il faut expliquer
pourquoi alors il est normal
il ya deux types de personnes il ya des
personnes pour qui le sait pas un
problème
le don d'organes et c'est quelque chose
de naturel il n'y a pas de réserve
et puis il ya des gens qui ont des
réserves pour des tas de raisons
personnelles dans goise de religion il
faut qu'ils fassent leclerc avec même il
ya une réflexion à faire là-dessus avec
avec les personnes qui ont une
importance pour eux est vraiment pas les
culpabiliser mais il faut mettre cette
angoisse ou cette réserve où cette
résistance qui est logique pour certains
avec le fait est incroyable c'est de
voir un devoir à côté de vous parfois
assis devant vous une personne qui
serait morte
oui et qui vit pour très longtemps
que ce soit en enfants ont aussi
toujours les enfants parce
qu'effectivement on est très émotive sur
les enfants mais un adulte c'est pareil
du levain en trente ans c'est pareil
et donc il ya cette angoisse avec d'un
côté et puis cette évidence d'une
personne qui continuent à vivre avec
l'organe d'un autre ombre l'une nombre
de l'ue ne vient nous rejoindre sur le
chat de youtube merci de nous suivre en
direct nombre de lune merci pour votre
bon jour et votre et votre commentaire
c'est moi qui vais sourire dit-elle
bonjour tout le monde merci pour ce live
et
professeur maurice mimoun tout le monde
est un donneur potentiel d'organes et de
tissus
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que alors que le plan législatif dans la
loi si on n'a pas mis sur une liste le
fait qu'on était refusé le don d'organes
le don d'organes et en trimestre
possible ça se fait avec beaucoup de
précaution avec la famille mais c'est en
théorie pas la famille qui décide et
heureusement c'est quelle responsabilité
de demander à quelqu'un d'autre s'ils
ils ont le droit ou pas donc je crois
que la loi est bien faible de ce point
de vue là et bien justement à propos des
lois évidemment il ya une loi qui
encadre le don d'organes cette loi
allait elle et elle est mal connue on
peut le dire aujourd'hui par par le
grand public
et comme vous disiez à moins de s'y être
opposé de son vivant tout le monde est
un des miens un donneur potentiel qu'est
ce qu'elle dit exactement cette loi
précisément par rapport aux donneurs
d'organes
elle dit que dit que c'est jamais par
malheur d'arriver malheur à la personne
est bien le médecin pourrait prélever
toutes les organes possible il ya
beaucoup d'orgueil un compromis mais je
suis d'abord on y reviendra
oui
sans accord d'autres personnes se fait
pas comme ça en réalité
en réalité le médecin sont beaucoup plus
précautionneux et voilà donc qu'ils
arrivent à obtenir les accords des gens
quand il n'y a pas d'opposition
donc on va dire pour pour résumer que si
vous ne dites rien on part du principe
que vous êtes d'honneur sauf si vous
avez estimé que vous ne donne ne riez
pas une fois décédé leur accident ou de
vieillesse
sauf si vous aviez exprimé dans un cadre
familial ou amical
le fait que vous ne souhaitiez pas nous
sommes d'accord merci michael adolfo
martin et soares dos suivre en direct
sur le chat ou youtube du figaro megal
qui nous dit je suis donneur d'organes
depuis 2009 depuis les années passent et
j'ai déménagé alors je dois refaire ma
carte d'organes et où dois je je la
refais remercie d'avancé pour votre
compréhension ne diminuent elles une
question sur un donneur il doit se
signaler avec une carte puisqu'il est
donneur mais est-ce qu'il ya nécessité à
le faire aujourd'hui avec cette nouvelle
loi qui date de départ il n'y a pas de
la société maintenant si dans son
portefeuille il ya un papier qu'il le
dit simplement ce feu ça facilite les
choses
on va donner quelques chiffres
communiqués par l' agence de la
biomédecine en france plus de soixante
trois mille personnes vivent grâce à un
organe greffé en 2018 5805 greffes
d'organes ont été réalisés dont 561 61
une greffe à partir de donneurs vivants
la greffe la plus fréquemment pratiqué
un c'est la greffe du rein avec 3560
greffe effectuée ans en 2018 et puis on
pense évidemment au greffe du foie au
greffe de poumons de coeur là je viens
de citer maurice mimoun des organes mais
on n'en connaît pas ou on connaît bien
les greffes d'organes on en a beaucoup
entendu parler ce qu'on connaît moins ce
sont les greffes de tissus et qu'est ce
que ça veut dire les greffes de tissus
de quel tissu parle-t-on alors on peut
on peut greffer pratiquement tous les
tissus mais moi je suis utilisateur de
deux greffes de tissus la peau la peau
des grands brûlés ne pourraient pas être
sauvées s'en sont donc de pau alors là
la peau est un tissu pour moi c'est un
organe parce que c'est extrêmement fait
la gueule et on prélève effectivement la
poche et sur les personnes décédées ça
nous permet de la place et chez les
genres en manque de pot par la brûlure
pour que cette peau prennent de manière
à ce que pendant un temps pendant un
mois on puisse faire de la réanimation
et prélever le reste de peau qu'ils ont
sur eux pour essayer de les faire
cicatriser autrement dit l'homme sans
peau moeurs et la greffe de peau va nous
servir de manière temporaire à le faire
survivre pendant pendant le temps qu'on
le soigne donc là c'est encore un peu
différent ce titre nous sert de manière
provisoire pour passer un cap
mais sans lui les patients seraient
morts donc quand vous voyez des grands
brûlés s'il n'y avait pas eu de dons
d'organes et ben extrêmement ce que vous
êtes en train de vous expliqué maurice
mimoun quelque chose que je ne savais
pas personnellement sur la greffe de
peau en particulier je pensais que la
greffe comme beaucoup d'entre vous
certainement de pau en particulier était
fait sur l'individu lui-même à partir de
sa propre poche
là vous nous parler de don de pau depuis
des donneurs qui sont décédés
mais ce sont des grès finalement qui
sont provisoires sur les greffes
provisoire c'est à dire que lorsqu'un
patient est brûlé à 70% 70% de son
capital de pau n'est plus là donc il va
falloir recouvrir avec sa propre peau
les 30 % qui restent les 70%
on a des tas d'articles et son prélève
des couches très fines de la sur les 30%
donc la peau repousse sur ses 30% et on
la place ailleurs mais voyez bien
qu'avec 30 on peut pas faire 70 donc il
faut attendre que ça cicatrise sur les
30 pour replacer sur les soixante dix
une deuxième fois
en attendant on met de la peau de
donneurs de manière à ce que le patient
continue à vivre parce que si on laisse
un patient sans peau il meurt il
s'infecte il se dénutri il me respecte
et se dénude
donc on est là pour vous parler de la
vie sauve de personnes malades grâce au
don d'organes grâce à la greffe en
présence du professeur mimoun qui est
avec nous ce matin pour une petite heure
et pour vous parler de ces dons et de
cette grille de ces grèves qui existe en
france et vous sensibiliser justement à
ce sujet qui n'est pas simple
effectivement qui n'est pas facile et
qui peut faire peur on l'a vu au début
de cet entretien on va préciser que en
matière de greffe de tissus bien aussi
il ya des grèves de temps dont il ya des
greffes de valves cardiaques de dos
d'artères également ce sont aussi des
greffes qu'on connaît moins ouais voyez
tout le lil'hoc de valves cardiaques
ça fait vivre quelqu'un qui serait bon
aux organes à proprement parler on
parlait du coeur ont parlé des reins
évidemment qui sont les organes les plus
greffé en france j'ai cité quelques
chiffres puisque on parlait de 3560
greffe de rein qui se sont eux qui ont
été faites en 2018 en france car elle
nous écrit que l est
et pas greffé du rein mais concernant
les reins artificiels elle à cette
question est ce que ce sont est-ce que
cette question des rares artificielle
est à l'étude
est ce qu'on peut espérer bientôt
prendre un médicament pour remplacer la
dialyse est ce que vous pouvez répondre
à 40 sur ce sujet là oui évidemment
toutes les recherches vont ensemble
évidemment que si on n'avait pas besoin
de greffe d'organes etc ont remplacé les
choses par des organes artificiels on
serait content toutes les recherches ils
vont tous les horribles et il ya des
domaines de recherche dans tous les
organes évidemment leur artificier si
elle ça existe déjà
ça existe mais c'est une grande machine
on peut pas traîner sa machine analyse
un saladier c'est la dialyse et la
dialyse ça s'ouvre les gens mais c'est
quand même une prison puisque on doit y
aller
plusieurs fois par semaine ses fils très
fatigant et les gens reprennent une vie
sociale avec un israël fait qui est
normal c'est extrêmement important
il ya un manque de greffe de rein pour
le savoir il ya un manque d'organes
actuellement pour quelles raisons manque
d'organes peut-être parce que le manque
d'organes peut-être n'y a pas à celles
de cd ça c'est tant mieux
particulièrement sympa mais la case
yannick merle et puis des personnes qui
ne donne pas également bon j'ai encore
une fois je pense pas qu'il faille les
juger mais le le
voilà on ya une limite ce qu'il fait
qu'effectivement le don d'organes c'est
l'avenir
mais l'avenir c'est aussi aux argana
trop artificiel ce sera peut-être un
passage aujourd'hui en tout cas on en a
besoin
merci encore dit s'ils vont direct sur
le chat du figaro figaro live et sur la
chaîne figaro de youtube où vous êtes
quelques uns déjà à nous faire part de
vos commentaires
fabrice nelson spezza en particulier sur
youtube bonjour fabrice bonjour depuis
le brésil je veux savoir pourquoi être
donneur d'organes est aussi savoir si le
don d'organes est un business et issus
d'affaires pour ça excusez moi je vais
essayer de d'être plus clair il nous
écrit donc lui depuis le brésil il
voudrait savoir si le don d'organes est
un business et si c'est une affaire pour
certains instituts sanitaires alors en
l'occurrence
en france le don d'organes n'est pas
sujet à transactions financières vous
savez le don d'organes en france est
très codifié il est bien sûr gratuit
c'est une évidence éthiques
je peux vous raconter une histoire
l'épreuve au dos au début de ma carrière
il n'y avait pas encore de greffes de
peau on donnait pas sa peau ça se
faisait on nous appelait mon patron
m'avait demandé de ne prélever on nous
appelait parce que il y avait quelqu'un
de décéder on arrivait on avait à peu
près d'accord on arrivait dans un lieu
c'était la mort est on prêt auprès ont
prélevé la peau et on partait avec le
petit le greffon dans la marre
maintenant s'était pas qualifié
maintenant tout est codifié les orbes
sont claude hi fi etc
alors ça c'est en france je pense qu'en
europe si codifié
on peut pas considérer que le don
d'organes est un business un fabrice et
à propos de cette question justement de
tableau nîmes il est anonyme également
certains pays je pense à l'espagne
rémunère ou en tout cas indemnise le don
d'organes beaucoup de gens en france
vous disiez il ya un manque d'organes un
manque de dons les gens ne donnent pas
suffisamment et puis il faut que les
gens dans la majeure partie des cas
décède pour pouvoir être prélevés on va
dire pourparlers très crûment
pourquoi ces temps incertains on n'a pas
prévu de favoriser le don en france avec
des rémunérations des indemnisations qui
permettrait justement de favoriser
évidemment d'un point de vue éthique
horrible on va arriver
d'abord on va pousser les gens on ne
sait pas qui poussera qui a donné un
organe parce qu'on peut pas manger quoi
donc cesser je suis certain que ça ne se
passera jamais en france et il faut
souhaiter que ça ne se passe jamais
alors que l'espagne rémunère parce qu'il
ya des frais et cetera peut-être mais
c'est déjà une c'est déjà une glissade
je crois qu'il faut vraiment faire
attention si on commence à mettre des
limites qui sont floues selon le nombre
d'organes s'est adonné et gratuit
c'est un don généreux
et pour son prochain on va dire on
parlait de greffe de rein de dons
d'organes et de greffe de rein on avait
eu cette question de carême qui
pensaient qu'ils s'interrogeaient sur
sur la recherche concernant des terrains
artificiels
quand on est greffée du rein maurice
mimoun
est ce que on peut subir des
conséquences est ce qui a des
conséquences médicales à ce conte pour
le donneur à qui on a retiré un rein
est-ce que handicapé suite de sa vie ce
qu'il fallait d'abord dire c'est que
évidemment on a parlé de personnes
décédées mais il ya donc aux requins qui
est encore plus formidable c'est ce sont
les dons de personnes vivantes
parce que l'on a on a la chance d'avoir
quelques organes qui sont doubles ou
dont on peut prendre une partie le foie
le rat voilà le et donc de son vivant ça
ça fait partie de reins le foie c'est
son développement pour faire de son
vivant
ben oui a donc donc d'abord là il ya une
procédure médicale qui est extrêmement
précise
les gens passent devant on peut pas
donner un organe même si on en a envie
très fort à sa soeur mer un enfant etc
ce parce qu'on en a envie comme ça il
faut passer d'un comité on voit les gens
voient les psychiatres et c est après il
ya un jugement qui est fait on s'assure
qu'il ya pas de pression et les choses
sont faites il ya un risque vital à
donner un organe qui est faible
extrêmement faible mais qui est pas nul
donc il faut avertir les gens de cela
aussi c'est risque vital il est au
moment du prélèvement dans la suite
d'éléments faisant alors dans la suite
de la vie il ya peu de conséquences mais
dans le prélèvement lui-même il ya
toujours un risque
comme pour toute intervention donc c'est
pour ça que c'est quand même quelque
chose il faut faire avec précaution qui
est très faible je veux pas découragé et
ça c'est un nom
ceux d'ibm merveilleuse sont des gens
qui font ça je pense et ses organes je
me rappelle plus la question malgré
pause après bien voyez vous m'avez vous
avez perdu également sur le don de son
vivant en fait est ce qu'il ya des ah
oui est ce qu'il ya des conséquences est
ce qu'on est handicapé
quand on fait un don de son vivant d'une
partie de son foie ou d'un terrain alors
il ya une cicatrice oui mais c'est une
belle cicatrice témoigne un témoignage
d'amour
miguel dolf au martinez soirée sur le
chat de la chaîne youtube du figaro qui
nous dit grâce à la greffe en espagne un
jeune après sa mort a réussi à sauver
cinq personnes cet excellent l'espagne
est un pays dans lequel les donneurs
sont très nombreux à donner leurs
organes
michael ados adolfo martin est ce qui
fait référence donc à des dons d'organes
de donneurs qui sont décédés mais on
vient de parler avec le professeur
mimoun des dons d'organes qui peuvent
être faits de notre vivant en
particulier les dons de reins et deux
fois
est-ce qu'il faut forcément que les
compatibilités absolue entre le donneur
et le receveur pour être donneur alors
il ya certes c'est un peu complexe et à
certaines qu'on tape compatibilité qui
sont nécessaires il on sait qu'un
greffon va mieux marché lorsque certaine
compatibilité existe n'est pas tout
et puis on peut faire des exceptions
donc là c'est vraiment affaire de
spécialistes et ça dépend des organes on
imagine que la science que la médecine
travail à faire des tests à élaborer des
potentiels greffe ou des prélèvements
sur d'autres organes que ce qu'on a cité
est ce qu'aujourd'hui
on a entendu parlé il ya quelques mois
de greffe d'utérus d'une femme qui avait
été greffé d'un utérus était une avancée
médicale elle a pu avoir et donner
naissance à un enfant
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on travaille sur
des greffes dont on aimerait qu'elle
aboutisse qu'elle puisse aboutir mais
qui sont aujourd'hui impossible à
maîtriser une des plus difficiles
c'était la peau et on est arrivé à faire
des greffes de visage on est arrivé donc
ce qu'ils avancent c'est pas tellement
l'organe à prélever ces les moyens qu'il
me soit pour qu'il ne soit pas le jeu
paraît gers et les landes la première
greffe du coeur on a pu tenir peu de
temps parce que le technique dedans anti
rejet net des plats bonne et ça ça
avance énormément peut-être qu'un jour
on pourra prélever avec d'été avec des
médicaments
ça c'est une ce serait une grande
avancée qui n'entraîne pas de délai de
deux problèmes secondaires parce
qu'effectivement il ya des effets
secondaires au traitement anti rejet
dont on ne parle peut-être pas assez
mais qui existe aussi c'est pas tout
facile ce médicament qu'il faut prendre
jusqu'à il faut se rendre sa vie il faut
prendre tout au jeu suivant sa vie cela
peut entraîner là du coup certains
inconvénients ces patients sont
surveillés
par exemple la peau on peut faire des
petits cancers cutanés on peut faire
d'autres choses qui sont traitables
également mais donc il ya une
conséquence sauf pour leur à ces gens
seraient morts oui voilà on va dire que
effectivement quand une personne est
greffé elle est elle un parcours de vie
qui est ensuite balisé jusqu'au jusqu'au
bout de sa vie on disait elle est suivie
on fait attention effectivement que les
médicaments anti rejet à fonctionne
correctement giallo et entraîne le moins
d'effets secondaires et plus ça va plus
on sait les deux et j'ai plus donc l'on
en donne moi et on en utilise qui sont
qu'ils sont moins néfaste dia bk sur
youtube merci dia de nous solliciter
avec vos questions vous est impatiente
ou impatience et je ne sais pas si vous
êtes une fille ou un garçon
mais sur le don d'organes et
l'organisation on va dire qu'il s'occupe
de gérer le don d'organes en france on
peut peut-être répondre à cette question
pincez vous faites-le mission avec l'
agence de la biomédecine genou a bien
mettre ces déshérités qui s'occupe de
gérer tout ça qui le gère et qui le gère
très bien il y avait encore une fois
parce qu'il ya aussi les skis et règle
ce qui est très compliqué c'est qu'il ya
des ja des greffes
non c'est pour certaines pathologies
qu'il faut faire en urgence il ya des
gens qui se mettent sur une île il est
temps pour des maladies chroniques donc
il ya tout là un staff qui dit non là
maintenant il faut le faire en urgence
on prend l'organe alors qu'une personne
n'attendait on s'est fait de manière
éthique je pense très bien fait une
question un peu folle que j'ai pour vous
maurice mimoun maintenant il ya quelques
années un scientifique en italie déclaré
qu' une promettait avec à court terme
même puisque c'était à peine quelques
années ils seraient en mesure de greffer
des têtes sur des bustes d'humains
est-ce que sa réelle relève d'une
réalité plausible ou c'est du fantasme
il avait déjà bien dit parce que le
congrès fut peut-être effectivement son
grès encore sur une tête par la tête une
peinture au corps c'est le corps qui va
compter
qui comptera puisque le cerveau et dans
l'antenne c'est techniquement je dirais
presque facile techniquement c'est
facile techniquement on peut le faire je
pense que ce serait bon il ya bien un
jeu assez facile ça ce serait à la
portée de beaucoup de chirurgiens
simplement ce qu'ils veulent ce qui va
alors après tout le mécanisme anti roger
ça c'est un autre débat mais
techniquement de brancher une tête qui
resterait vivante sur un corps c'est
possible la seule chose c'est que ce
qu'on veut c'est très mal maîtrisée
c'est les communications nerveuse
d'ailleurs que ce corps serait
complètement paralysé là on n'a pas du
tout du tout réseau lee c'est le
problème du passage des neurones et de
la mobilité encore complètement inerte
sur donc le fonctionnement du cerveau
est à ce point mystérieux et complexe
qu'on ne pourrait pas faire la connexion
et on va dire la grève du cerveau si on
ne sait pas collecter les moelles encore
là bas sinon ils peuvent juste c'est
vrai est ce qu on a une idée de du
moment dans l'histoire ou les premières
greffes ont ont débuté et qu'elles ont
été concluantes on va dire on a essayé
des greffes alors je pense que ça doit
être très très ancien mais dans le civil
dans l'actualité dans les dents des
temps modernes
on a greffé des
on a fait des greffes de rein animal de
s'imposer des ports de 1900 j'ai pas les
dates en tête et il ya des publications
ça tenait quelques jours et puis les
gens mouraient mais on a beaucoup à
espérer avec sa puis on a fait des uns
fait des greffes avec d'autres personnes
c'est même l'histoire le programme des
premières organes ou tissus qui le
transférait de manière commune celle
sans la transfusion sanguine sans rien
n'a été inventé de bras à bras au départ
et pendant la première guerre mondiale
je crois et le effectivement et de temps
en temps ça sauver les gens puis de
temps en temps je savais pas pourquoi
parce qu'on connaissait pas les
compatibilités avec les rôles charia et
humour est si vous venez nous rejoindre
en direct sur figaro l'arrivée sur la
chaîne youtube de figaro live nous
sommes avec vous ce matin et le
professeur mimoun pour répondre à toutes
vos questions en lien avec le don
d'organes et la greffe
nous avons déjà répondu à un certain
nombre de vos questions sur le sujet
mais on va reprendre peut-être une
question essentielle principal beaucoup
s'interrogent en effet qui peut être
donneur aujourd'hui si on veut donner
est ce qu'il ya une limite d'âge dans le
don d'organes de son vivant ou bien
quand on est décédé vivant il faut être
majeur de céder non mais la limite c'est
d'être d'avoir des organes qui sont
efficaces
donc c'est vrai que plus on avance en
âge - les organes sont efficaces et
selon les organes et selon l'urgence on
peut prélever assez tard quand même on
imagine aisément que c'est aussi
d'hygiène de vie du donneur l'iran
j'm'en en considération au moment du
prélèvement et au moment de la mort on
parle de donneurs malade on parle de
deux malades âgés également concernant
les enfants est ce qu ils peuvent être
donneur receveur et à partir de quel âge
alors ils peuvent être seuls ils peuvent
être receveur à n'importe quel âge et
ils peuvent être demeure avec
l'autorisation de céder avec
l'autorisation des parents mais ça peut
ça peut arriver également rêver parmi
les questions que les internautes se
pose on parlait tout à l'heure de l'
agence de la biomédecine y en a une qui
revient souvent c'est la question sur la
fameuse liste d'attentes commençons
disent décidés les règles d'attribution
des des organes qui est prioritaire qui
ne l'est pas c'est vrai que beaucoup
s'interrogent sur les temps d'attentes
on dit souvent que certains greffe et
attendent des mois voire des années que
certains même décède à faute d'avoir
trouvé un donneur mais qui décide c'est
l' agence nationale qui décide
et comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure ce
si on prend le foie il en ya des
hépatites fulminantes ou si on ne grève
pas le ce sont des gens souvent jeunes
et sur les grèves pas immédiatement la
personne meurt alors qu'elle a une
espérance de vie
un sens serait donc évidemment ils
peuvent doubler une personne qui
attendrait pour une maladie une cirrhose
chronique millière qui a requis non
s'est-elle tour mais qui va rater son
tour pour 7 pour pour cette hépatite
fulminante parce qu'on estime que
l'autre personne a encore un peu de
temps devant elle donc il ya ça il ya
aussi la proximité parce qu'on n'a pas
le passé il faut transporter les organes
dépend des régions il faut voir un peu
on peut pas transformer il ya des avions
mais enfin il ya quand même plus on
attend pour trente ans c'est toute une
organisation comme l'organe a il faut en
avoir la cohérence entre la personne
qu'on va prélever et la personne sur
laquelle on va mettre lauriad donc il
faut qu' il faut qu'il y ait deux
équipes de chirurgie qui travaillent ce
raccord des ultras coordonnées et elle
est absolument prouver plus le temps est
long entre la période ischémie c'est à
dire une fois qu'on a coupé le sang qui
arrivent dans nos organes et une fois
qu'on l'a réimplanter plus le risque
d'échec de ce transplant va être
important où il va il va moins bien
marché donc la qualité du greffon qui
est en transit entre le donneur et la
personne qui va recevoir le plus 7 ans
et court mieux c'est y aurait plus on
s'éloigne de ses agents initial est donc
comment résoudre selon résout ton ça la
première chose c'est essayer de que le
receveur et l'honneur soit pas trop loin
ça c'est la première chose après il ya
les transports il ya des mécanismes
menant d'avion de l'ambulance qui sont
extrêmement rapides
il y à des produits qu'on injecte dans
le dans le transplant qui retarde la
dernière la dégradation des tissus et
puis maintenant ce qui est très très en
vogue je dirais très en retard
c'est con
on fait des perfusion artificielle c'est
à dire qu'on va prélever leurs organes
et qu'on va le brancher à une sorte de
coeur artificiel qui pendant le
transport va le leur et oxygéné ça nous
fait gagner d'un tandis qu'emi ça veut
dire le temps où l'organe n'est pas
oxygénée - non ce que vous voulez dire
professeur maurice mimoun mais ça ça me
permet de rebondir sur effectivement un
constat que fait bérengère 50 qui nous
dit d'ailleurs bonjour bérengère j'ai
une tante qui dont ça fait un peu plus
de deux ans qu'elle est dialysé et trois
ans et demi qu'elle est en attente de
greffe cp effectivement c'est un temps
très long avec l'espoir chaque fois
peut-être appeler quand on est appelé on
nous dit finalement que ça sera pas pour
ce coup là c'est assez terrible parfois
elle sans attendre ce terrible alors
peut-être at-elle d'abord il ya des
temps d'attentes très longes
effectivement parce qu'il ya un manque
d'organes aussi et peut-être est-elle
dans une configuration à la des
anticorps difficile où il faut trouver
un organe un peu compliqué et oui ça il
ya aussi des problèmes de très pratique
de compatibilité de la taille de
l'organe et et de la taille du thorax de
thé la personne tout à fait recevable il
ya des tas de critères qui comble les
rangs gère 50 qui ajoute un c'est une
attente si longue alors qu'on lui avait
dit il parlait à l'origine de 8 à 12
mois d'attentes et là on est sur trois
ans et demi devant vous et pleurent tous
et tous les tous les chirurgiens déplore
on essaye de l'esprit humain est
incroyable parce que on arrive à diviser
des organismes c'est à dire un fois on
peut le diviser en deux voir en 3
parfois pour sauver trois personnes vont
sauver deux personnes deux personnes
avec 1 seule fois un peu sauvé deux
personnes c'est formidable
là je voulais aborder avec vous la
question délicate du prélèvement et le
moment que se dessine le prélèvement
c'est une question qui est posée la
famille dans l'est dans les minutes à
peine ou dans les heures à peine qui
suivent le décès de la personne et du
défunt comment en amont avec des
journées comme comme celle d'aujourd'hui
on parle du don d'organes et de la
greffe est ce qu'il faut nous nous mêmes
nous préparer à ce qu'un jour peut-être
on soit confronté à cette question du
corps médical sur la possibilité de
favoriser le don de la personne que nous
connaissions qui vient de décéder et de
dire oui à cette demeure dans un moment
aussi douvres
alors vous avez compris que c'est plein
de questions claires et c'est une
information
c'est une information vettel ont fait
leur rentrée ce teaser c'est pas une
queue alors ça se pose en question et
qu'on aimerait que la famille dit oui
les gens sont très entraînée d'abord il
ya les méchants diam il ya toute
l'équipe de 30 chanteurs
c'est effectivement extrêmement
difficile parce que ça doit être pris la
décision doit être pris dans leur quoi
mais les gens que les gens le font c'est
ça qui est admiratif qu'il faut
améliorer plus tôt jean-marie donc on va
dans une situation concrète peut-être
expliquer comment ça se passe vous avez
un membre de votre famille un ami qui
vient de décéder et le personnel médical
va juste vous demander non pas si on
peut prélever mais si de son vivant
cette personne avait exprimé le souhait
d'être donneur c'est sa conscience que
c'est le grand nord et vu que s'opposer
ou avait dit qu'elle s'y opposaient s'il
a les membres de la famille
ne savent pas que se passe-t-il à ce
moment là est ce qu'elles peuvent s'y
opposer elle-même ou est ce qu'on y va
quand même invité sa situation comme ça
ça peut sembler brutale la façon dont je
raconte
non non non mais c'est vraiment ça
peut-être les questions que tout un
chacun se pose je moi je n'ai jamais vu
dans ces conditions là mais le
d'habitude la famine ment pas donc soit
soit elle ne sait pas et elle va là elle
va l'accepter
soit ce wali qui s'est elle te poser on
respecte la volonté du défunt
on s'interroge également qu'est ce
qu'ils arrivent au corps du défunt
après le prélèvement on imagine que le
circuit entre guillemets n'est pas le
même pour une personne qui décède à
l'hôpital une personne qui décède et sur
laquelle on va on va prélever quelques
organes qu'est ce qu'il advient du corps
alors d'abord il est dans un bloc
opératoire la personne est morte
le coeur bat et olé la personne et le
bloc opératoire et un certain ordre dans
le prélèvement des organes aussi quelque
chose de très technique et ensuite le
le défunt est réparée c'est à dire qu'il
est présenté à la famille comme s'il
n'avait pas été prélevé donc on pratique
les mêmes gestes chirurgicaux de
refermer à baver sur avec beaucoup de
chance et c'est à dire que le corps mort
que c'est de prélever et recousus avec
autant de choix qu'une personne n'ayant
évidemment ils reconstituent et donc
énormément de respect évidemment il faut
rassurer aussi des gens sans cela ça va
être du défunt il faut comprendre il
faut comprendre qu'un bloc opératoire on
a l'impression que le chirurgien qui a
non c'est une équipe c'est une équipe
avec beaucoup de personnes et il ya le
respect il ya un grand échange si jamais
il y avait quelqu'un qui soulève qui un
jour vous les battez chose il serait
immédiatement remis en place il ya eu la
valeur de l'équipe la confiance de
l'équipe
une question de bérangère 50 toujours
sur la greffe de rats et l'exemple de sa
de sa tante qui s'interroge quand on est
déjà greffé on garde le greffon déjà en
place
plus le nouveau et jusqu'à quel âge
peut-on être greffés c'est vrai qu'on
additionne les greffons dans le cadre
d'une greffe de rein
alors ça dépend comme comment l'ancien
l'ancien l'ancien en marche
s'il devient pas toxique ce
il ya plusieurs possibilités mais
effectivement si là encore fonctionnel
on peut en mettre un deuxième à côté
vous savez qu'on branche pas l'oral à la
place où il était en maison mais un peu
plus bas en plus d'accord ça fonctionne
ça fonctionne pareil oui et jusqu'à quel
âge
ça dépend des ça dépend des spécialités
il ya la fusée qui a l'âge physiologique
il ya des moments où l'espérance de vie
fait que on préfère laisser les greffons
pour des personnes qui ont plus de
chance que c'est quand même des
interventions un peu lourdes où on sent
là peut-être l'inquiétude du côté de
bérangère 50 sur jusqu'à quel âge
peut-on être greffés on imagine
peut-être qu'elle part d'une personne
qui n'est pas jeune peut-être et donc il
peut être s'inquiète de savoir si elle
peut encore être greffés malgré un âge
peut être en place il faut le dire son
greffon va durer très très bon ski de
fond va durer très très longtemps
très bien on le disait certaines
personnes sont parfois opposées au don
d'organes par par croyance ou par
méconnaissance du sujet est-ce que les
il faut il faut essayer de les
convaincre de donner leurs organes et si
oui comment les convaincre par quel
discours je crois qu'il faut pas
confondre convaincre il faut expliquer
respecter parce que on ne peut pas faire
l'unanimité on a pas de vérité absolue
mais encore une fois cette résistance
aux dons il ya une partie de la
population qu'il là et c'est normal et
c'est énorme c'est complètement normal
et si on s'arrête là effectivement on
dit pas de dons mais il faut mettre à
côté de cette réticence normal c'est pas
naturel du tout
il faut mettre avec elle à côté un
enfant un adulte vivant qui va mener sa
vie qui va se marier qui va tout faire
quoi et donc là il ya une balance dans
cette balance les choses deviennent plus
équilibrée il faut laisser après à
chacun
le choix de décibels qu'est ce que vous
même vos confrères qui ont pu en
témoigner
entendez comme témoignages de personnes
de patients qui ne souhaitent pas être
greffés est ce qu'on sait précisément
sur quelle peur ça puisse et ses refus
ou cette résistance en général la peur
d'être greffé sur la peur de donner des
repères d'être greffé des deux côtés la
peur d'être au greffe il ya des gens qui
il ya des gens qui ont peur des
interventions il ya des gens qui
préfèrent la dialyse gens qui ne veulent
pas qu'ils montent donc là aussi c'est
qu'il ya toujours un risque donc on peut
on peut pas pousser comme si c'était une
évidence les choses aux donneurs je les
dis il faut il faut mettre cette balance
des deux côtés soit discuté les
religions sont différentes les ailes ont
eux aussi évolué dans leur foot est
aussi en parler avec son son maître du
culte je crois qu'il faut vraiment les
ccc une discussion éthique extrêmement
compliqué je pense pas encore une fois
c'est facile pour certains c'est
extrêmement compliqué pour d'autres et
bien fois arrivé à essayer de sortir un
avis l'important c'est de deux à un
moment donné c'est à dire non oui parce
que il ya beaucoup de gens qui préfèrent
ne pas poser la question je vous demande
et vous risquez de vous décalez un tout
petit peu sur votre droite parce que
vous sortez du card me dit-on en régie
vous estimez vous même personnellement
qu'on ne parle pas suffisamment de ce
sujet publiquement qu'il faudrait que
c'est ce sujet du don d'organes et de la
greffe soit quelque chose qui deviennent
un peu commun dans les médias dans notre
vie du quotidien qui vous fait le job et
des rats non il ya une journée par an
pour pour le nombre d'organes ont je
crois qu'on en parle pas mal à la
télévision je crois que c'est pas le à
la voie radio dans les journaux je crois
que les gens sont informés savent que ça
existe ça a beaucoup moins l'aspect
spectaculaire qu'avant non c'est
toujours la même chose si on veut qu'ils
aient une réflexion c'est dans les
écoles que ça doit être dès l'enfance
c'est dès l'enfance on doit en parler
les enfants supportent beaucoup plus que
les adultes
c'est la discussion sur ces choses là on
a peur d'en parler mais il faut leur
parler ils se feront leur opinion il
faut l'éduquer à l'école c'est vrai
expliqué qu'effectivement les enfants
sont sensibles à ces sujets là ils ont
peut-être moins d'appréhension parce
qu'ils sont les moins de la priorité
moins d'à priori que nous les adultes on
peut être donneur et ne pas vouloir
donner certains ses organes
est ce qu'on peut faire une sélection va
dire sur ce qu'on souhaite donner deux
mètres de votre corps donc vous avez le
droit où il ya eu viol peut-être
certaines croyances certaines religions
font qu'il ne faut pas prélever de tel
ou tel organe oui bien sûr je pense je
me pose cette question parce que je
pense a effectivement la greffe de
cornée en partage également et donc le
fait de toucher aux yeux j'aime beaucoup
de gens même qui serait d'honneur dans
l'absolu du reste de leur lancer
l'intention que c'est une sorte de
d'inconscient de quelque chose de
culturel qui fait que les yeux c'est
quelque chose de locker aussi celle
l'étaient beaucoup hein
on pensait on pensait le coeur c'est le
c'était là où il y avait la main on m'en
donnait maintenant
charvaux donc ce sont des organes
symbolique instant morgan travel vous
parliez tout à l'heure de l'anonymat du
don d'organes en france
est-ce qu'on peut malgré tout choisir la
personne à qui d'un autre organe
absent lors n'ont jamais et heureusement
puisque cet anonyme est donc
complètement généreux maintenant les
greffons familiaux de donneurs vivants
c'est c'est possible parce qu'il ya une
seule une question de compétence bien
meilleur qui fait que l'organe va durer
toujours
donc là on ne revient on par exemple au
don de rein jeu j'ai une personne de mon
entourage qui a besoin des deux l'a fait
je donne à mes reins à cette personne je
sais que mon rein va aller à cette
personne-là l'anonymat ils devaient
total de la levée gré rats fois et vous
savez que j'ai moi j'ai pratiqué
absolument petit revenir sur cet
événement extraordinaire qui agit en
2007 comme je vous ai dit la peau est
rejeté et on peut pas la tenir sur un
boulet alors on pourrait dire non mais
on me le pôle un cadavre en la gare
pendant des années c'est trop dur par
contre on va rappeler les faits c'est un
monsieur qui a été pendant le capt
sonder sa profession extrêmement pour
les grands brûlés à plus de 95 % l'ont
quelque 95% les gens malheureusement on
n'a pas les moyens de les tenir et il
aurait dit il aurait aimé rire et de
l'humour y est un jeune homme de 30 ans
une famille extraordinaire
vous apprenez par hasard j'ai jamais par
hasard que je vois son frère mais ne me
dis pas que le jury le plus sur le son
jumeau est défigurée donc je vois pas la
ressemblance est un moment donné mais je
veux donner beaucoup beaucoup de gens
disent je voudrais donner ma peau pour
pour mon frère pour moi pour mon enfant
pour c'est impossible ça sauf que là ils
étaient jumeaux julie mais ça suffit pas
et lahi les jumeaux homozygotes c'est à
dire qu'il vient du même heure c'est à
dire qu'il a la même génétique et là
tout s'éclaire sauf que la législation
est bien fait en france
ce cas n'était pas prévu et que
l'horreur était que je savais que
j'avais vu que j'aï le savez si je veut
prélever mais je n'en ai que d'éloigner
vous le permettez pas c'est un texte de
loi ne disait rien parce que comme je
vous ai dit le donneur vivant il faut un
temps on lui donne un temps de réflexion
il peut pas prendre tout d'un coup la
décision et deux jours après celle
opérée et c'était lui qui aime et on est
arrivés dans les temps comptait les de
temps comptez donc on a appelé les
autorités etc
ils se sont réunis en urgence et ils ont
accepté et je vais en remercie je les
remercierai jamais elle c'est parce que
aujourd'hui les vivants parce qu'on a pu
prélever son jumeau trois fois on a
prélevé
comme je le dis la peau régional
régénère ont la preuve les trois fois
quinze jours d'intervalle et ainsi son
frère est recouvert de la peau de son
jumeau qui exactement la maca points à
15%
c'est fantastique ce lien qui les unit
on imaginait le lien qui les unit alors
j'ai découvert la gémellité que c'est un
lien extraordinaire et puis le lien
qu'il a avec nous et puis je viens
d'avoir un bébé
je me dis quand même jeu pour un médecin
c'est incroyable absolument pas dire que
l'un coupe on a sauvé vie de quelqu'un
qui aurait dû mourir et il a donné la
vie c'est pas une personne c'est à dire
c'est incroyable si vous vous rejoignez
en ce moment en direct sur figaro
l'arrivée sur le chat youtube du figaro
nous sommes en direct depuis d'autres
studios pour vous parler du don
d'organes et de la greffe en provenance
du en présence du professeur maurice
mimoun
nous parlons du don d'organes qui est un
sujet un peu difficile mais auquel vous
avez beaucoup de questions une nouvelle
question en l'occurrence de bérangère 50
qui nous demandent si je fais un rejet
puis-je être regreffer c'est vrai que
c'est une question intéressante sont
peut-être regretter après bien sûr là on
va il ya plusieurs choses il ya l'organe
qui n'est pas efficient qui marche mal
pour pas parce que le disque emi a été
trop longue c'est à dire le temps
pendant lequel il n'a pas été oxygéné le
transport ou autre chose
et puis on peut faire ça c'est le c1
s'est rapidement il y à l'échec
chirurgicale qui est rare et puis à
l'organe qui n'est pas toléré parce
qu'il ya un rejet trop important donc il
faut analyser pourquoi est on peut on
peut parfois pas toujours là je peux pas
rentrer dans les détails regret flex est
effectivement alors là on parlait de
regreffer le même organe sur la même
personne est-ce qu'on peut être regret
fait plusieurs fois mais de différents
organes greffés plusieurs organes
différence sur coup mon par exemple ils
sont souvent y faire ensemble
c'est un peu plus rare d'avoir cette
greffe qui est particulièrement lourd
tandis que l'insee plus rares mais mais
mais parfois c'est le même plus pratique
de faire les bleus ensemble plutôt quand
est ce que une personne greffée
peut-elle peut-elle elle même être
donneuse
au cours de sa vie je crois pas
c'est une bonne question mais je ne
crois pas peut-être que le greffon non
le défenseur caennais sont en bon état
peut-être que c'est faisable
alors peut-être pour la cornell vous me
posez une colle je vous ai posé une
seule jeu
toute façon il ya un bilan de l'état de
l'état du patient on peut même
malheureusement malheureusement encore
ouverts décidé que l'organe n'est pas
bon après je verrai ça c'était une
question c'est un aspect que peu de gens
savent on peut au moment où on prélève
l'organe m'avoir câble
l'athérosclérose je vois là il va pas
supporter jusqu'à mi mai au moment du
prélèvement n'est d'accord comme vous
l'expliqué tout à l'heure il ya une
coordination avec d'autres équipes ça
veut dire qu'il ya une personne
potentiellement receveur qui attendaient
ce domaine aux chômeurs et finalement ne
leur a pas et donc on arrête tout et
c'est terminé il faut attendre de nos
quelques mois évidemment c'est très très
insupportable mais avant qu on ouvre on
va dire la personne qui est donneur on
s'est quand même assurer au maximum on a
déjà fait un bilan d'abord c'est déjà un
bilan de global mais là aussi il faut
quatre fois les vides donc qu' on est
obligé de ne peut pas lui faire tous les
autres bien sûr mais on imagine ce genre
de mauvaises surprises on va dire et
est assez rare oui on peut pas l'exclure
merci encore nous suivrons en direct sur
figaro l'avait sur youtube merci pour
vos commentaires vos questions votre
intérêt pour ce sujet qui n'est pas que
ce n'est pas facile
notre émission touche à sa fin arrive à
sa fin on était en présence de maurice
migou le professeur maurice mimoun qui a
eu la gentillesse de nous accorder
quelques minutes de son temps précieux
pour répondre à vos questions en direct
au figaro nous avons à tenter d'être le
plus complet possible on espère qu'on
l'a été et alors on espère vous avoir
idée sur le sujet peut-être vous avoir
encouragé un peu plus à peut-être être
donneur merci -8 6 min pour votre
expertise sur le sujet des greffes et du
don d'organes j'aimerais que la banque
qu'on se quitte à 1 consiste votre
engagement au sein d'une association que
vous avez créée et mise en place qui
s'appelle skin for all qu'on pourrait
traduire par de la peau pour tous vous
êtes le grand manitou on va dire de la
greffe de peau c'est une association
vous venez de créer pour faire avancer
la recherche sur sur la peau avec
l'ambition de parvenir à créer une peau
comme difficiel synthétique synthétique
haute mais pour magique surtout une peau
qu'on puisse mettre sur n'importe qui
lequel viennent de quelqu'un d'autre ou
qu'on a ou qu'on a qu'on a construit
nous mêmes donc skin for all et est une
association qui pousse un chercher dans
ce domaine de la peau parce
qu'aujourd'hui concrètement vous disiez
au début cet entretien le greffon de pau
b il ya ces histoires de compatibilité
évidemment qui sont difficiles
l'utilisation il recourt à 10 ans
dirigeait cette association je voulais
faire depuis longtemps
et puis c'est un fait les frais depuis
car un de mes amis qui qui à l'occasion
d'une chanson qu'il a le fait j'ai dit
que j'allais j'allais venir
effectivement donc cesser c'est un
journaliste on va le site effectivement
frédéric picard qui s'est investi
personnellement dans votre combat en
écrivant effectivement une chanson et en
demandant à au talentueux mélodiste
léonard lasri de 10 mètres aussi sa
patte et
cette ville elle-même de l'association
et le but c'est vraiment de trouver la
peau universel c'est à dire qu'on peut
ramer comme mais ça peut être décliné
sur tous les organes leur anniversaire
ça sera peut-être de la peau de donneurs
mais alors là plus le jumeau tout le
monde c'est à dire que par le jumeau on
a vu qu'on pouvait le faire il faut
qu'on arrive pas à sauver des vies en
faisant une peau artificielle ou une
perte d'honneur mais qu'ils soient qui
tiennent toujours et pour tous mais pour
toujours
est ce qu'on peut vous demander
précisément à partir de quelle matière
peut être réalisé une peau artificielle
un coup de synthèse
alors il ya des matières qui sont
complètement synthétique ça existe pour
les des rousses avec la peau c'est le
derme et l'épiderme
on arrive à faire des derme après ces
deux ça peut être des pots de culture on
peut prélever ça peu être des postes ça
peut être des pots complètement
synthétique avec du silicone
il ya énormément de domaines de
recherche il ya aussi de l'immunologie
qui fait que ça tiens ça tiendra
peut-être mieux ou pas vous savez que la
pause très difficile à construire c'est
le mettre un tissu de pause c'est une
chose mais la poya des poils il ya des
ports et je verrai donc il faut
absolument tout reconstruire ces trois
des coins un temps que c'est d'une
reconstruction prades est donc là aussi
on espère avec des machines 3 3d de
reconstruction 3d qu'on va y arriver
donc tous ces domaines de recherche sont
ensemble il y en a une qui va y en a une
qui va sortir
à quelle échéance vous espérez que cette
peau artificielle synthétique puisse
voir le jour être alors de demain c'est
à dire vous savez la recherche on trouve
dont on ne trouve pas pendant longtemps
puis un jour il ya un mais clair on ne
sait pas donc c'est improvisé mais
j'espère demain il ya plein de plus
merci encore professeur maurice mimoun
être intervenu en direct on dire une
chose alors je suis pas donc le trans
oui j'allais dire j'allais rappelez vous
inquiétez pas d'ailleurs on va revenir
sur ces justes par rapport à frédéric
picard ce journaliste du figaro qui est
investi personnellement et qui a créé
cette chanson avec léonard lasri le
mélodiste pendant que je courais ben
vous pouvez la télécharger sur n'importe
quel site de streaming
pendant que je cours dont on doit
pouvoir voir la fiche en tout cas la
pochette du single
vous pouvez donc l'écouter comme je vous
disais sur toutes les plateformes de
musique en streaming et c'est donc
l'hymne de votre association fondée sur
by means for all dont on voit également
le nom s'afficher ce qui ne pourra le
point org
exactement et vous êtes le parrain en
parallèle de cette association
transforme point org
qui est donc cette association qui fait
la promotion du don d'organes et
encourage et à qui on demande aux gens
de faire des poèmes sur les la greffe
d'organes et aura un jury qui décernera
c'est pour sensibiliser au don d'organes
il y aura un jury qui dira quelles sont
mes meilleurs poèmes merci encore
maurice mimoun pour votre intervention
directe dans les locaux du figaro depuis
nos studios sur ce plateau et merci
encore à tous d'avoir témoigné et
d'avoir poser vos questions on était là
pour vous et on est très heureux d'avoir
pu vous aider et vous éclairer à très
bientôt sur figaro live et sur la chaîne
pierrot live sur youtube
merci beaucoup